lava from Hawaii's Kilauea volcano is
spreading to new areas and residents are
reaching their boiling point a man was
arrested after pulling a gun on a
neighbor and shooting it yesterday
during an argument scientists say the
lava flow is getting hotter more fluid
and faster covering about six football
fields in an hour during the four week
crisis molten rock has spread across a
four and a half square mile space of the
Big Island that's more than three times
the area of New York's Central Park
Carter Evans is in Paha Ye where some
residents are ignoring evacuation orders
Carter good morning good morning take a
look at this explosion of lava behind me
a fountain this size creates rivers of
molten rock those can block roads
leaving people who refuse to evacuate
with no clear way out as huge amounts of
lava continue to spread new aerial video
shows how it's forming channels in the
hardened rock and it's moving fast
according to geologists Scott rolling
it's a self-made lava channel the sides
solidify and then the part in the middle
continues to flow and those channels are
very efficient the lava flows are
unrelenting and unpredictable to give
you an idea of how close these eruptions
are coming to people's homes this is a
fountain of lava that's probably a
hundred feet tall and it's right up on
someone's backyard
ongoing tensions is leilani estates may
have contributed to this shooting
incident Tuesday 61 year old John
Hubbard is now under arrest accused of
opening fire and allegedly assaulting a
neighbor who came to check on his
property the victim was injured but was
not shocked just as I sighs hi this is
strange people in their subdivision and
they're trying to protect stuff and the
crisis continues lava has already
overrun the main road highway 132
leaving people in about five hundred
homes and vacation rentals with just one
escape route left if the flows cross
Highway 137 there would be no way out
workers have started to dig out a new of
equation drought but that could take
weeks and now two military helicopters
are on standby they can evacuate about
45 people at a time you're just trying
to keep it from getting to that point
absolutely we don't want that to happen
the danger is real the number of homes
destroyed jumped from 41 this week to
more than 70 now authorities say it's
natural for people to want to stay in
their homes until the very last minute
but they also say for those that
affected communities that last minute is
now
gaile gotta pay attention to what
they're saying thank you very much
Carter Evans reporting from Hawaii